here's the thing though and this gets
into the next topic
what about fans what about as we get
deeper into the season more and more of
these states are allowing fans to be
present you know if i'm a team that has
enough fans at my games that i'm
actually making money or my fans would
be pissed off beyond all belief if they
don't get to come watch a home playoff
game they've been waiting for years in
tampa to come watch a home playoff game
if that would happen for the buccaneers
how do you justify that and i mention
that because the saints are currently in
a tug of war with new orleans to have
more fans at the superdome and the
saints are exploring playing games
at lsu stadium in baton rouge 80 miles
away so they can have fans there because
not because they're trying to chase the
dollars because we've talked about this
before the dollars aren't really there
but you've got
fans partners sponsors who are upset
that the saints aren't doing more
to get new orleans to let them have
fans present so
if you
start taking home playoff games away you
are running the risk of fans being very
upset at losing the opportunity to go
see their favorite team play at home
chris because more and more of these
stadiums are allowing it yeah i i mean
it's still not a big number i mean it's
not like all i mean 7 500 fans it's not
like it's gonna 25 000 in dallas okay 25
000 in dallas yeah
well that may be one of the bubbles so
maybe i have 25 000 people there for all
those games yeah i mean if they can do
it the right way and everything like
that then i mean i got no problem with
fans at a game or whatever i mean yeah
new orleans i mean i do think it's weird
that like now we got teams trumping like
local cities like screw your rules we'll
we'll make our own rules and move out of
here that that to me is a little weird
all right um but but all in all i mean
do what you got to do i don't know what
else to say there and yeah i just hope
the nfl can keep everybody safe with
fans in the stadium and everything like
that
yeah and uh look it's it's an issue
that's going to continue to hover over
the season i think that home market
bubbles for the playoffs would be fine i
don't think you need to have neutral
sight bubbles i think you can play the
games in the cities but they're going to
want to have no margin for error when it
comes to the postseason because you're
right you can't postpone a game you
can't press pause on the playoffs yeah
what are you gonna do you're gonna
forfeit a playoff game people would lose
their minds especially if we get through
256 regular season games with no
uh forfeits of any kind and as i've said
before i think they are determined to
have no forfeits because they still have
to pay the players arguably if there are
forfeits if games are canceled they
don't have to pay the players
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports